il n'y a pas de doute l'inde grouille de
monde
sa population et près de 40 fois plus
importante que celle du canada des
entrepreneurs canadiens constate bien le
défi dans le contexte de se faire
remarquer ce plus connus pour les
indiens d'aller aux états unis et il
pense que c'est une opportunité un plus
grand pas pour les indiens de deux
cherchent des opportunités commerciales
aux etats unis canada et des cibles ont
déjà été ratée en 2012 sous le
gouvernement un peu lundi le canada
espérait voir leurs échanges commerciaux
atteindre 15 milliards de dollars en
mais même aujourd'hui ils ne sont que 2
8 milliards devant des centaines de
délégués de compagnies canadiennes et
indiennes réunis en marge de sa visite
justin trudeau tenet a annoncé que tout
n'est pas figé
alors qu'ils parlaient de plus de 5000
emplois créés et 2 milliards de dollars
d'investissement au canada
son entourage a dû rectifier ses propos
la majorité des investissements iront à
l'aise pour ce qui est des compagnies
indiennes
elles investissent entre autres dans les
secteurs de pointe les industries
numériques et pharmaceutique
le fondateur de la compagnie
pharmaceutique indien du bénin a par
exemple indiqué que 100 millions de
dollars iront à l'agrandissement de ses
installations à kirkland au québec
c'était la journée de la visite de
justin trudeau en aide
entièrement consacré au commerce avant
le départ son bureau avait bien pris
soin de diminuer les attentes
on ne prévoit pas de développement
majeur dans les pourparlers en vue d'un
traité de libre-échange ou sur la
promotion et la protection des
investissements étrangers
mais avec les annonces faites
aujourd'hui justin trudeau pourra quand
même dire qu'il ne repartira pas les
mains vides ici madeleine jay mohr et
radio-canada mumbai